now we are going to take an
uncomfortably close look at a befuddling
online trend in a segment we call
@midnight deep dive the Internet it has
something for everyone to masturbate to
nowhere is this more true than on Amazon
where Amazonian authors produce digital
stories where humans get it on with
dinos Griffin's and all manner of beasty
both historical and mythical but the
master of this genre is a mysterious
figure named Chuck tingle who since 2014
has written over 80 micro novels with
titles like space Raptor blood invasion
or creamed in the butt by my handsome
living corn I'm listening yeah and my
favorite happy birthday Frankenstein now
pound my butt
it's that Frankie sighs looks like 70s
Hulk I don't know what that is
comedians what is a line that you might
read in this amazing erotic horror tale
Willem coming so hard Gene Wilder could
feel it all right boy uh Bridget fireman
paid attention to balls good it's that
show it's that show
Frankenstein violently ripped off his
own head so he could easily suck his own
yes now the reclusive mr. tingle is
incredibly prolific churning out super
down there is one who is Chuck tingle
no one knows and is driving me King
bananas I have combed his books for
clues for research I've had I've had my
entire staff here scour the internet I
went to the pet store and shoved a gecko
up my butt hoping he'd appear but the
only thing that happened but the only
thing that happened was that I could not
stop ejaculating and I say 15% or more
on my car insurance
here's what we do know his name is most
likely a pseudonym his author photo is
some kind of stock photo from a stock
photo site so comedians what's a title
for a PowerPoint presentation that might
use these stock photos Bridgette oh that
looks like life after your wife takes
the kids away all right points uh Rollem
Taekwondo thank you all right boys
Justin dying alone and how to do it
all right boys so the Eagle Eye tingle
detective will find some clues on his
YouTube channel so let's take a still
from the trailer for his book but
ception of course that's what you love
which you mean or there's a lot more
Justin there's so much more so but
ception features a house with the
address 703 I'm sure you guys remember
703 so here's where it gets weird listen
listen this is serious gets weird this
week is weird
this is the hard part listening Chuck is
trolled men's rights activist Vox Dei
who once appeared in the podcast the Tom
woods show episode 703 alright in his
videos tingle also wears a bag on his
head just like the performance art piece
by Shia LaBeouf who is often lesson
after on Twitter by at Mary Jane 703 who
lives where in Alexandria Virginia area
code 703 oh there's more
I know I know scoop your brains back
into your head because you're gonna need
them to process it
if that doesn't blow your minds of the
703 people watching the show then how
about you in the 50th edition of the
Catholic University Law Review we found
a case that has to do with sodomy on
page 703 the name of that case Bowers
versus Hardwick oh my god oh my god I'm
in this too
first of all I was innocent
second of all the only explanation I
have is to be the subject of his next
book so comedians what should be the
name of my tingle story
well jingled out by singled out part
deux yes very good
Bridget tingle Me Elmo Chris Hardwick
gets soft yes must account in cold water
Justin
action-figures I've sat on on purpose
all right points points uh so you can
see I'm very passionate about this so I
would like to talk to chuck himself
right Chuck Chuck if you're out there I
admire your prolific nature and insane
creativity and I would like nothing more
than to be the subject of one of your
erotic yarns that you spin on the Amazon
in fact I'm gonna give you a cover image
to start the process we set the mood
disco ball alright I know
punks in here please
yes
should get your creative juices flowing
put me on your book go write your
masterpiece guys I would like you to
tweet Chuck tingle all right
tweet Chuck tingle and tell him Chris
Hardwick be very specific Chris Hardwick
deserves to have his butt pounded by
some weird creature or objects make it
happen
you